18h12 où j'avais perdu l'aller où tout
le monde sait ce quiz aujourd'hui se
trouve sur moi to you do if que feriez
vous si sortez vos copies vous avez deux
heures 8 sur 21 pour la figure et un
cours cette blague on arrête que feriez
vous si vous pouviez arrêter une
catastrophe on rêve tous deux pour faire
ça le 11 septembre le massacre colombie
où tes résultats d'examens non non non
arrêté non mais pour s'est même pas
arrêté s'est passé pas la peine ok on va
pas se mentir là trop dur pour ce club
le fdp imputait raison qu'on n'en fait
pas partie quoi qu'est ce que tu ferais
si tu rencontrais un alien improbable tu
essayé de le tuer je vais essayer de le
raisonner ou tuteurs fuiraient et on
peut pas juste fume un bep d'eau et
moins d'alcool avec lui ok ok arrêté je
sais que c'est les vacances vous arrêter
vous n'êtes pas sages aujourd'hui c'est
chiant vous continuez j'arrête moi je
pense qu'on part en cours aa je vous
l'avais dit 22 % des gens partent encore
en 9 % de beauf le tue sans même lui
dire bonjour
attendez on parle d alien depuis des
centaines de putin d'année et quand on
est devant toi comme ça tu le suis de
balle dans la tête
15 9% résonne wallace et parle avec lui
ben oui bah oui bon que ferais tu si tu
te mettais avoir faim bas je me fais des
des coquillettes fromage comme toute la
france qu à la fin tellement ou pas allé
dans la cuisine et de cuisine et de la
nourriture
appelez quelqu'un qui te donnerai la
nourriture donc sa sphère libre et 61 %
des gens font l'effort de se lever et
d'aller cuisine est à 2016 puisque
c'était que ferais tu si l'internet
disparaissait la géo pour l'emploi tu te
remettrait à regarder la télé non sauf
capital et zone interdite et tu irais
dehors ou alors tu aurais les nerfs
étaient série de redémarrer ta box toute
la journée
c'est un peu ça 26 % de gens s'acharnent
27 % sont des traîtres et 47% il est
dehors baisse à cake pokémon go ami a pu
interne qui a pu piquer mon boulot pas
de hausse assez intéressant que ferais
tu si tu pouvais masterisé un instrument
du piano de la guitare du violon
franchement du piano franchement du
piano à un message les acheter pour
apprendre est ce que j'ai appris banon
c'est un début que feriez tu situe
possédé illégalement une arme à feu
quoi la garder pour ta protection tuer
quelqu un ou plusieurs personnes la
donner à la police je vais pas vous
mentir je suis un peu contre les arts
moi quand j'ai les nerfs le gène nerfs
et si j'avais un gun j'aurais tué dit
jean donc alors bains wc très bien son
arme les policiers sont ceux qui ont les
armes ce sont ceux qui nous protège ils
sont trois ils sont carrés vive la
france
votez pour moi suivant que ferais tu si
tu étais le chef d'un hôpital avec un
seul coeur disponible pour une
transplantation sauver le président des
états unis on s'en bat les couilles
sauver quelqu'un au hasard avec une
famille aimante et adorable ou sauver
dexter morgan
on va quand même sauvé le petit garçon
qui a besoin d'un coeur pour continuer à
grandir au sein de sa famille à doit
répondre dexter morgan duthes exigeant
que ferais tu si soudainement tu avais
des super-pouvoirs quel pourcentage de
chances pour que ça arrive bien tu te
battrais contre les crimes battu
commettraient des crimes utiliserait des
pouvoirs pour toi même au va pas ce véto
à un moment 2016 d'individualisme
j'arrive plus à parler l'individualisme
l'égoïsme le je pense qu'avant à
m'habiter pas celle du voisin est ce que
là si je fais ça je suis pas bien si la
conca qui va se mettre dans ma main
franchement pourquoi j'utilise rsa pour
arrêter les balles des méchants et on va
pas se mentir que je choisirais tu
entres ces quatre propositions les
insectes des 24 fois plus gros à mon
dieu juste passé avec tout ce que tu
connais commenceront à le détester pour
ce poste change pas allez je serai payé
moins de 100 $ par année
mais non mais des insectes c'est le
moins pire mais c'est horrible c'est
horrible que ferais tu si tu devais
retirer l'un de taissy sens la vue
l'ouïe ou le booba le goût et je pense
qu'on a tous mis le goût ans c'est
horrible c'est vrai le cap est une tout
est fade la vision et louis c'est quand
même bien longtemps que le goût je pense
que mon avis le goût 70% 20 millions 14
% de gens et c'est [ __ ] quand même 22
% de gens qui préfèrent perdre la vue ou
le men on est d'accord on préfère tous
perdre le goût que la vue l'ouïe super
la vue l'ouïe tu peux plus regarder
l'épisode cuisine avec c'est abusé allez
champions je ferais tu si tu pouvais
voir dans le futur ça c'est beau tu
joues avec le marché financier donc ça
te fait fortune en une seconde tu
préviendrait le monde des catastrophes
qui arrive alors ça ça j'ai une sur eddy
et sillage revenait par exemple avant
les attentats ou quoi et je prévenais
les gens je suis dit qu'est ce qui se
passe de 1 personne va te croire de deux
personnes à croire tu vas peut-être et
en asie mais que quand ça va arriver
le fbi a il va choper par la peau du cul
et va te dire comment tu savais ce à
quoi tu vas répondre je suis dur
tour du fait qu elle a donc s'il y en a
parmi vous qui vient du futur fait
attention que ferais tu si donald trump
gagner les élections qui avait vu au
canada
tu mangeras une pierre où tu ferai la
fête je mangerai unearth stone le jeu le
joueur tonnes je n'ai jamais demandé
vous abonner à que ferais tu si tu
devais vivre avec un singe qui
deviendrait très agressif si tu ne fais
pas l'amour avec lui une fois par mois
si tu n'as pas de relation fusionnelle
et plein d'amour mais non sexuels avec
lui ou si tu te maries avec lui et tu
deviens comme n'importe quel couple
marié bat le deuxième à avoir une
relation super proche de lui mais s'en
sortir tu habites tout mon ami ça bien
sûr que choisir du service trois
propositions manger son chiot manger
sans araignées vivantes août marié
sérieusement avec une vache pendant 30
ans à ça mon père l'a fait donc si tu
veux je viens au nom je t'aime annoncé
tuer sans je suis au pas les manger
à pita e-mails qui revient de chine qu
un bon je suis enfin aujourd'hui suis
désolé question suivante je refuse de
répondre que ferais tu si tu étais
psychiatrique ton patients te disais
qu'il allait tuer une femme tue le
report à la police
et tu perds ton taf barreyat le la loi
du secret c'est horrible tu reste
accroché à tes principes et tu gardes le
silence au curry ji de tuer quelqu'un
que tu détestes le psychiatre qui a
besoin lui est d'aller chez les
psychiatres à moi je le balance
franchement tu peux pas parce que tu es
en thérapie chez pas quoi le laisser
faire le laisser ôté la vie à quelqu'un
tu peux pas alors tels que chute opus
peut-être que je suis dans mon monde de
bisounours
laissez moi un chargeur ya quand même 53
% des gens qui feraient ça aussi et 22%
et qu'ils demanderaient tuer quelqu'un
qui déteste je perds foi en l'humanité
que ferais tu si tu devenais une
araignée tu essayé d'avertir tes amis et
ta famille tu accepterais ton sort et tu
verrais une vie d'araignée ou tu
marcherait sur les gens pour explorer le
monde mais oui mais où il tient on tue
pour cent des gens presse avait bien sûr
que ferais tu si tu te réveilles sur le
titanic au moment où il vient de quitter
le port essaie de convaincre l'équipe
que le bateau va couler suite en furet
dans un canot de sauvetage et au fdp
août et s'est retrouvé rose
j'avais à dire c'est pas moi c'est moi
je suis dans mon cadeau est en train de
partir là et benjamin de cette vidéo sur
que feriez vous si je perds ça va plus
c'est cannes n'était pas les mecs comme
d'habitude mais j'adore ce genre de jeu
parce que c'est une sorte de petit
sondage en fait voilà on se rend compte
un petit peu de qui fait quoi dans
quelle situation on se rend compte que
on est beaucoup de fils de [ __ ] c'est
faux mais qu' on a des petits qui feint
chacun je veux dire est une araignée
grimper sur les gens c'est un bon motif
pour certains aller on a toutes ces
conneries allez allez vous-en c'est la
fin je vous dis à très deux prochaines
vidéos tient tout le monde pousse à vous